c'est la dernière fois que je m'exprime
publiquement avant un procès ces mots
prononcés en préambule de la conférence
de presse montre la détermination du
procureur de la république
dans un document de 27 pages qui sera
remis aux autorités chiliennes en vue
d'une extradition
étienne manteaux détaille les éléments à
charge contre nicolas zepeda et ils sont
nombreux les témoignages d'étudiants qui
logeait au même étage que narumi
kurosaki font état de cris dans la
chambre de la jeune fille dans la nuit
du 4 au 5 décembre 2016
une anglaise en voit même un sms dans
lequel elle dit on dirait quelqu'un
qu'on est en train d'assassiner ya les
cris il ya un bruit sourd
certains diront comme un corps qui
frappe quelque chose mais très vite
quand les plus courageux parce que
beaucoup disent en avoir très peur à ce
moment-là et tétanisé rester dans leurs
champs
au moins trois personnes vont sortir
dans le couloir passez plus rien le
calme est revenu les personnes ne
préviendra la police
et puis il ya les 980 messages échangés
entre narumi et nicolas zepeda entre fin
août et le 8 octobre 2016 qui montre la
dégradation des relations entre les deux
jeunes gens narumi avait un autre petit
ami ces messages corrobore la vidéo mise
en ligne par nicolas zepeda elle ne peut
pas commettre
il faut qu'elle assume elle a deux
semaines pour se rattraper
deux semaines pendant une semaine après
l'assassinât présumé des messages
rassurants sont envoyés depuis le compte
facebook et line de la jeune japonaise
un billet de train et même acheter en
utilisant ces numéros et codes de cartes
bancaires
la transaction a été faite depuis une
bande d'un centre commercial de dijon or
les enquêteurs en ont la preuve nicolas
zepeda s'y trouvait à ce moment là mais
narumi elle n'a pas été vue dans le
train des éléments de vie qui cesse le
12 décembre justement au moment où
nicolas zepeda est de retour au chili
enfin à son cousin de barcelone chez
kinloch quelques jours avant son retour
nicolas zepeda parle de narumi au passé
elle aimait beaucoup la mer dit-il un
élément de plus pour des enquêteurs
persuadé de la culpabilité du chili